With studios eager to build as much hype as
possible before their films are released,
March has been a fire sale month for new movie
trailers.
"Oh, my God!
We're having a fire… sale.
Oh, the burning!
It's burning me!"
Over the course of the month, we saw new trailers
for high-profile releases like Infinity War,
Deadpool 2, and Fantastic Beasts: The Crimes
of Grindelwald, along with some exciting first
looks for upcoming films like the Sicario
sequel and Action Point, to name a few.
With so many movies big and small on their
way to theaters in 2018, it's a lot to go
through.
Here's a look at the trailers released in
March 2018 for films that we're getting excited
about.
Wildling
From IFC Midnight, Wildling is a horror thriller
about a young girl named Anna who's thrust
into the modern world after spending her whole
life being raised by her father in the woods.
She's put in the care of a police officer,
played by Liv Tyler, who soon realizes that
there's something strange about the girl.
In particular, Anna can't seem to shake her
fear of a local legend about a ferocious beast
called the Wildling.
There's a lot to take in from the trailer,
which sort of hints that Anna may be the mysterious
Wildling.
"He ate all the other children.
You're the last one left."
Hopefully that isn't the movie's main plot
twist, but even if it turns out to be, Wildling
at least looks like an enjoyable ride.
Wildling hits theaters and video-on-demand
services on April 13th.
Avengers: Infinity War
With another full-length trailer for Infinity
War released this March, Marvel is definitely
cashing in on the hype.
Set to an emotional rendition of the original
Avengers theme, the newest trailer hints at
a plan to make Thanos come to the Avengers'
home field to secure his Infinity Stones,
and of course offers more glimpses of the
epic superhero team-ups we're all waiting
for.
Tony Stark and Peter Parker hash out a plan
with Peter Quill and Drax.
Captain America hitches a ride with T'Challa.
Thor brings the lightning with Rocket and
Groot.
It's like getting all the ice cream flavors
on one cone.
Well, minus whatever the Hawkeye flavor is.
Very Berry?
Look for Avengers: Infinity War on April 27th.
Terminal
What is this movie about?
The teaser gives nothing away, which is, admittedly,
what teasers are supposed to do.
Most of the visuals simply show a pair of
feet in high heels walking down a candlelit
aisle.
Margot Robbie headlines Terminal, and her
voice over in the trailer hints at dark happenings.
Mike Myers and Simon Pegg are also slated
to star in the film, although their roles
are still just as much a mystery as the rest
of Terminal.
This train's riding into the station on May
11th.
Deadpool 2
Deadpool 2's trailers have all revealed something
new, and this one sees Deadpool putting together
the X-Force team - with plenty of action along
the way.
While the first trailer was mostly filled
with jokes about the film's CG and writing,
this one touches on the story a little more,
revealing that Cable is on a mission involving
Julian Dennison's character and giving a little
more screen time to the new cast of mutants.
At this point, we're all definitely hyped
for Deadpool's second coming on May 18th.
Action Point
Judging by the trailer, Action Point will
lie somewhere between a scripted film and
a Jackass stunt showcase.
The film draws from the real-life Action Park,
a notorious New Jersey waterpark.
"I love it!"
"There's nothing i the world like Action Park!"
The park featured such attractions as Cannonball
Loop, a rickety waterslide that began with
a steep 45-degree drop and ended in a bone-crunching
full 360-degree loop before ejecting patrons
onto a plastic tarp being sprayed down by
an employee with a garden hose.
Yeah, it was that kind of waterpark.
So it should be no surprise that Johnny Knoxville
honed in on Action Park as the subject for
his newest movie.
It's the perfect canvas for painful, epic
stunts, and with Jackass mainstays like Chris
Pontius along for the ride, we're just crossing
our fingers that the movie production suffers
fewer casualties than the park itself.
"Let's see what this baby can do!"
Take the ride on June 1st.
Tag
Go ahead and and make all the Hawkeye jokes
you want, but you can't deny that Tag looks
like a fun film.
The story centers on five friends who have
spent most of the last 30 years playing the
same game of tag, for one month every year,
they engage in a no-holds-barred game of "you're
it," ignoring all social conventions while
the game is on.
Wedding ceremony?
Funeral for a father?
It doesn't matter as long as they can get
within tapping distance of each other.
"I think your dad would have really wanted
you to be… it!"
Believe it or not, Tag is actually based on
a true story about a group of friends who
have been doing this exact same thing for
decades.
It's not all lighthearted playground antics,
either.
It was this film, and not Infinity War, that
saw Renner break both of his arms performing
a stunt.
That's a little more hardcore than getting
together with your old friends for a game
of Yahtzee.
The game begins on June 15th.
Under the Silver Lake
From David Robert Mitchell, the guy who brought
us 2015's It Follows, Under the Silver Lake
is a surreal neo-noir mystery comedy about
a young man in L.A. who starts searching for
clues about a woman's disappearance.
The deeper he digs, the more he begins to
believe that there's a secret code embedded
in the world's media, with everything from
pop songs to cereal boxes hiding messages
for him to decode.
From the looks of the trailer, Under the Silver
Lake will be a swan dive into paranoia, centered
on a man who may have discovered the world's
biggest, darkest secret...or, he might just
be crazy.
Either way, the trailer promises plenty of
suspense, violence, and conspiracies, all
wrapped up in a quirky comedy.
Under the Silver Lake hits theaters on June
22nd.
Sicario: Day of the Soldado
2015's Sicario raked in huge amounts of critical
praise for its unflinching portrayal of Mexico
in the grip of a cartel war, although it wasn't
exactly the kind of movie that screamed for
a sequel.
Day of the Soldado will see Josh Brolin and
Benicio del Toro reprising their roles from
the first film.
Their job in Soldado is to push the Mexican
cartels into a full-on war, no matter who
gets caught in the crossfire.
"You're gonna help us start a war."
"With who?"
"Everyone."
Denis Villeneuve, who helmed the first film,
won't be returning as director.
The reigns are instead going to Stefano Sollima,
an Italian director whose previous credits
include 2015's Suburra and the TV series Gomorrah,
both of which focus heavily on organized crime.
In other words, he should be a good match
for the Sicario brand.
And with a script from Taylor Sheridan, screenwriter
of the original, Sicario: Day of the Soldado
ought to be just as powerful as its predecessor.
Look for it in theaters on June 29th.
The House with a Clock in its Walls
As a director, Eli Roth is best known for
movies like Cabin Fever, Hostel, and The Green
Inferno , you know, not the kind of stuff
you'd take your kids to.
So it may be surprising that Roth is set to
direct this upcoming children's fantasy film.
The story centers on a young boy who moves
in with his uncle, who enlists the boy to
help him find a magical clock in the house
that has to power to bring about the end of
the world.
In the trailer, we get our first look at Jack
Black as the uncle and Cate Blanchett as the
powerful witch who lives next door.
From the looks of it, The House with a Clock
in its Walls is turning into a slightly creepier
A Series of Unfortunate Events.
And with Steven Spielberg's production company
Amblin Entertainment behind the film, it should
be a whole lot of fun.
Look for it on September 21st.
Fantastic Beasts: The Crimes of Grindelwald
Newt Scamander is traveling to Paris in the
latest trailer for Fantastic Beasts: The Crimes
of Grindelwald, where he apparently bumps
into a young, handsome Albus Dumbledore, played
by Jude Law.
Dumbledore recruits Scamander to help him
put a stop to Grindelwald's plans.
This looks like the start of a magical journey
that will traverse the globe and, of course,
feature plenty of fantastic beasts to both
help and hinder our heroes.
From new shots of Johnny Depp as Grindelwald
to several scenes inside Hogwarts, the trailer
offers just enough to give Potterfiles a thrill
of excitement.
Fantastic Beasts: The Crimes of Grindelwald
apparates into theaters on November 16th.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!